monsieur cédric chaillot a tenu il
tenait plus précisément à faire part à
ce magistral son désaccord sur des
propos et sur un communiqué de presse du
syndicat
le représentant du syndicat
pénitentiaire
ce ses propos et ce communiqué de presse
parle de l'ennemi public numéro un
il titre le criminel le plus recherché
du centre pénitentiaire de ducos
il parle de 17 crime 17 morts dont 13
avec arme et bien évidemment la rumeur
publique
puisqu'on est en train de parler à ce
moment là de l'affairé du maximus la
rumeur au public désigne monsieur cédric
chaillot vouloir en diabolisant
quelqu'un qui est qui fit l'objet d'une
mesure d'instruction devant un juge
vouloir diaboliser cet individu bout je
ne sais quel avantage
je trouve que c'est incorrect que c'est
inadmissible que c'est inacceptable